The most significant mistake so many leaders have made in the last 20 years,...
...and it's very upsetting to me,...
...is that they've put their self-interest ahead of the best interest of the institutions...
...or organizations they run.
And that to me is the greatest failing of a leader.
If you're looking out for your own money, fame, power or glory, that's wrong.
As Peter Drucker said, leadership is not about those things.
It's about responsibility.
And I think it's a deep responsibility you have to the people you work with,...
...your customers, your employees, your shareholders and all those constituencies you represent.
And that's an obligation and carrying that responsibility out is the essence of good leadership.
I think the biggest mistake a leader can make or maybe the worst trait...
...a leader can have is to not be self-reflective.
So, the admired leaders that I've worked with...
...and the people just in my own day-to-day that I've apprenticed myself to and really wanted to follow...
...have been people who are constantly reviewing their own behavior,...
...who are thinking about how they can develop themselves and...
...thinking about how their behavior impacts other people.
So, I think unless somebody is willing to hold up a mirror to themselves and...
...have an honest to God conversation about how they're doing...
...or what effect their leadership is having and what effect they have on other people,...
...I don't think they'll be effective as leaders.
And I think, conversely, the people who are the worst leaders are people who just...
...bulldoze forward and plow forward through life,...
...making mistakes, not really looking back on the past, not learning as they go,...
...and not necessarily being self-aware about how they're affecting the people around them.